what is on the nose dialogue so on the
nose dialogue usually means your
characters are saying everything that
they're thinking there is no Nuance
there is no subtext
this can possibly be because like for me
I'm a very forward person when I speak
right so now all of my characters are
being very forward but most people are
not like that most people don't say what
they mean or mean what they say most
people don't speak very directly most
people you know shut down instead of
telling you what their feelings are most
people don't know how to tell you what
their feelings are in the first place so
if you've got two characters in a scene
and both of them can communicate
effectively then your screen plays over
because now they're not causing any
problems for each other right the other
part of that is and I want to be
careful when I say this there's a little
bit of poetry to writing dialogue right
there are puns and like a lot of the
greatest dialogue that we you know that
we think about are things that I
probably would not have said that in
real life you know what I mean so there
is a little bit of that that happens and
not everybody's good at that and that's
fine I'm not necessarily all that great
at it unless I'm writing like
oh southern women or men then I can give
them all the Poetry there is but that's
because I go around I grew up around
those people so I know the kind of
poetry that they speak right
um but generally speaking it usually
just means that you know on the nose
literally means like you can't miss it
it's right there and you want some of
that dialogue to be far more nuanced so
that you can play with everything else
in the scene the words don't have to
tell us everything so it's a little bit
of show don't tell right the words don't
have to tell us any everything how can
we find out other things or how can you
say this to me without saying it to me
right so there's like this uh I'm gonna
call it a meme I don't think that's what
it is but you know they say tell me
you're an 80s baby without telling
you're an 80s baby oh well one of my
first concerts was The Temptations which
probably would make me like a 70s baby
but you know I went I went with my
parents
right so but that would be my way of
saying that instead of just walking in
and saying I am an 80s baby I'd go well
my first concert was Prince and then
people will probably go okay you were
probably born in the whatever time so
the same thing is true with your
dialogue how can let's go back to our
young lady who's cursing out her mother
how can she show her mother that she's
upset with her
without saying I'm upset with you
that's how you're going to write
dialogue that's not on the nose that's
how you're going to get the subtext
that's how you're going to get the
Nuance so for example one of the uh
examples I love and hopefully I can
remember the name of this film it's
about Cowboys and it's on Netflix but
the Father the Son acts the father why
don't you love me and instead of the
father saying I love you and here are
all the reasons why he tells a story
about naming him
and it's because I gave you your name
that we understand he loves him he never
says I love you he never says no son you
got to believe it I love you instead he
tells this beautiful story about how he
chose his name
that's subtext that's Nuance that's not
being on the nose the on the nose
respond would be I love you
is there a way to avoid on the nose
writing
if you're good at it if you're good at
dialogue yeah if you understand
um nuance and subtext yeah but I think
generally speaking when you're starting
out
um most people watch TV and watch films
and what they take from it is just the
dialogue and they're thinking it's more
like a play where it's just you go I go
you go I go you go I go right and
they're not necessarily considering how
those words are pushing the story
forward or how those words can make the
reader feel as they're taking it in
because I always say the read is King
someone's got to read it before it gets
produced they're not thinking about the
pacing of it or how it could be dragging
the story because they're in this
conversation for so long and I think
that's something you have to learn over
time some people might like anything
else simply just be gifted at whether
they know that they're gifted at it or
not some people are just good at
dialogue but I think generally speaking
we've all written something on the nose
before with that being said sometimes
being on the nose is okay you know every
single line of dialogue is not going to
have subtext or no one's going to know
what we're talking about right like at
some point you got to say it out loud
especially if you're writing something
that's like science fiction or you know
something that's already pretty
difficult for us to understand like
something political
Etc at some at some point someone's just
got to keep it simple and make it very
plain about what's going on or we're all
going to be lost so sometimes on the on
the nose dialogue is okay and you won't
get that note about it you might get a
note that says I need somebody to just
make it plain I need someone to just say
it because we're all kind of lost in the
thoughts of what's going on here
um there can be dialogue that's too
poetic right like it's so poetic that we
aren't really having a conversation
anymore and we aren't really pushing the
story forward anymore we're just saying
nice flowery things right so I think no
matter what unless again you've just got
a natural Knack at it and some people do
that it takes a little while to figure
out dialogue especially because you're
writing for so many characters and not
all of those characters are going to
sound the same talk the same you know um
use the same Cadence in their speaking
Etc and so I think it's a skill set that
it takes a little while to kind of
figure out
how does a writer balance dialogue and
action in a scene I think it depends on
the scene
first of all each scene is pushing your
story forward so that means each scene
has a goal like a little mini goal of
the larger goal if you don't know what
that is you can get lost in the sauce of
your dialogue and your action right if
you're writing features
um features are pushed more by action
than dialogue that doesn't mean that I
need to literally see more lines of
action but it may mean that there are
more opportunities to remove dialogue
because action can tell me
um what it is that they could have said
so like I said before how can you show
me that you're angry without telling me
that you're angry right so instead of
cursing mom out I'm going to slam the
door and walk out right so now you got a
line of action instead of dialogue I
don't think that there's a particular
balance that has to be made it just
depends on what's Happening for the
scene I literally just gave a note the
other day because we were reading we did
a table reads we were reading the script
out loud and the action was actually
distracting because it wasn't necessary
what we needed to focus on were these
people talking because once it's getting
shot the director is going to give them
blocking right so they're going to be
moving around they're going to do stuff
so it's not or they won't because we're
just focused on their conversation it
depends on what the shot is and what
they decide it's going to be but
sometimes the only action that you need
is the scene description at the top and
you can just let the people go that
happens a lot more in Television right
because television uh these actors are
together all the time they've got a
chemistry the director is going to come
in and give them the blocking and so a
lot of the times you don't see a lot of
action in television episodes right
you'll see it when it's necessary as in
like we need her to pick up that cup
therefore the action tells her to pick
up the cup but other than that you might
not be you know you might not have as
much action as you would in the future
because they're moving in a different
rhythm in this TV series right so you
don't have to tell them what they need
to be doing all the time so you just
need to figure out again what am I
writing what is the format of what I'm
writing what's the genre of what I'm
writing in a horror there might be more
action because the action is also giving
me all of the feels you know what I mean
it's giving me all the jumps and the
scares and the blah blah blah and
obviously in an action film there's
going to be more action because you got
to write out those action scenes Etc
um whereas in a romantic comedy maybe it
won't have as much action or or in a
comedy maybe it won't have as much
action depending upon what the comedy is
right so just kind of figure out what's
necessary for you with the table read
did you do it again and just cut out the
action no because uh we do three writers
and we do it in two hours so really the
point is for the writer to hear it out
loud and make notes for themselves on
what they may want to change when they
go back for their revision so it's kind
of like a part of their revisions
process right so we talked about earlier
first draft second drafts Etc something
else you can do is listen to it out loud
right and I would suggest doing a table
read versus using any of the technology
that has it played back for you because
then you don't get the Rhythm right so
if it's a um a computer voice that's
what I'm gonna AI right then the the
Cadence is not the same right so now
you're not hearing it how you intended
it
um and then also a lot of AI uh may not
know what to read and what not to read
on the page and screenplays have all
kind of stuff on the page and so now
again it's messing up the Rhythm because
it's reading parentheticals and it's
reading all kinds of stuff right but in
a table read I have the actors read the
action and the die dialogue and the
scene headings because as the writer you
need to hear okay they're in the mall
and they're walking and they're having
this conversation does this work right
is the Rhythm working for me is you know
the amount of action and so this
particular script that we were reading
was a decently you know well put
together screenplay but it was just
every now and again I could feel the
writer inserting himself a few times to
give me a little action it's like yeah I
don't need that because now that's
dragging the read right and you pull
that out and I just want to be listening
to these people talking that's it you
know because it's again was TV so it's
like we're gonna get out of here and get
into the next scene so it's not about
having four or five pages I would never
suggest anybody have four or five pages
of only dialogue right there's got to be
some action in there because it's on the
screen it's pushed by action right but
generally speaking sometimes it's just
hey we're in the mall and we're walking
and we listen to them walk and talk and
we don't need to have any other action
unless they're stopping at a store
picking up a bagel whatever it is
they're doing you know what I mean this
is Al Pacino in a courtroom scene right
maybe
and even then it's going to be
interrupted with juror number one looks
to the side you know it's going to be
interrupted by something even if it's
not Al Pacino's action you know it's the
judge leans back you know you're gonna
get something else to just kind of
disrupt that flow of all of the dialogue
and I think it's great too when you
talked about an AI Voice versus a human
two if you see an actor possibly
struggling with something that's going
to tell you too because that made the
audience will struggle with it yep
exactly or or that the reader will
struggle with it or that the actual
actor will struggle with it and you'll
realize that even though where wherever
it is that you're from or with your
friends you guys speak this way and so
for you you know exactly what that means
and you're able to read it and then you
get someone else come in and they have
no idea what the context of this is and
they're flubbing over it you don't want
actors to flub right you want them to
just be able to read and go and so you
can take all of those notes for yourself
and go okay I need to check on that line
okay that line has it's a compound
complex sentence and it's and it's not
working maybe I need to make it a little
more simple you know what I mean get to
make those kind of notes for yourself so
it's great to to hear your words out
loud